I can't I can't take it off well he'll
must have frozen over because Jojo see
wha just ditched her signature bow the
16 year old YouTube star had her fans
totally shook on Tuesday when she hit up
Tik Tok to reveal what she looks like
without her iconic sky high ponytail the
whole thing kicks off with Jojo changing
into a bunch of different looks pony and
bow on full display before she drops the
bomb I mean can we talk about how
gorgeous she is and from the looks of it
she's stoked to be showing off her
day-to-day look just check out that
smile and before Jojo wowed us with that
toothy grin and hair sans bow she joked
about her famous style with this
tick-tock
I can't beat it I can't take it off she
captured the clip when people think this
is how it works
lol I can take it off but I'm not gonna
complete with what else up Oh emoji hey
it's Jojo and I'm super excited because
I am back to unbox the JoJo's
buh-buh-buh of March she even has a bow
of the Month Club guys clearly I need to
sign up there you go there's number 29
the box is so cute oh my goodness y'all
look at we got this cool pinch that's a
starting on my logo and a bone with the
Jojo charm
and here we go it's our belt et caught
up with Jojo back in November and she
opened up about this YouTube video where
she kinda sorta let her hair down I am
about to turn myself into a visco girl
feel like for the first time we saw a
different side of you in your latest
YouTube
you transform into a visco girl and I
should fire because you let your hair
out like you literally like this is the
first I feel like I've seen you with
your hair not in a pony snatched phony
to everyday really like it with my when
my hair is like that I like my hair up
in a messy bun and on my hair and to
grade
yeah but I hate but earlier this month
when we found out she was behind the
t-rex mask on the masked singer we were
super impressed that even under that
heavy costume that signature bow was
there and perfectly in place
[Applause]
[Music]